If you would have asked me two months ago,
I would have told you it was impossible for
them to invent something more boring than
my social studies class.
Turns out, I was wrong.
Virtual social studies on a Zoom call with
Mr. Hardesty is even worse.
Because with the real class I at least got
to see my best friends: Sinclair and Podge.
In fact, the last time I saw them in person
was a month ago, the day of the protests.
Ever since then, the police have been vocal
that nobody should attempt to investigate
the clown attacks on their own.
So naturally, we had a plan to investigate
things on our own.
While Mr. Hardesty was droning on about…
Honestly, I don’t know what, Sinclair, Podge
and I were chatting in a separate window on
Discord.
We had a plan to get some information.
See, while Podge and I aren’t exactly model
students, Calvin Sinclair is kind of a genius.
He’d been doing some of his own research
and was filling us in on his findings.
He explained things in our private chat: So
I started by pulling as many articles as I
could find.
Creating a database of all the attacks.
From there I mapped everything to get a visual
idea of where these incidents are happening.
I was hoping to find a higher concentration
somewhere, and maybe be able to determine
the source.
Podge asked him if we could see his map, and
he sent over an image.
I opened it up, and immediately saw the pattern!
The synapses in my brain were firing off,
and I was ready to reveal my discovery…
no of course not.
I had basically no idea what I was looking
at.
What do I look like, Bill Gates?
As far as I could tell, it looked like there
were attacks scattered… all around the country.
Other than the fact that bigger cities and
their suburbs seemed more likely targets,
there was no real pattern that I could discern.
Sinclair asked us if we noticed anything about
the map, and when we had no idea, he went
on to inform us he had two major takeaways
from it.
“Excuse me!
Who is that who just joined right
now?”
That was the voice of was my teacher, Mr.
Hardesty.
Apparently someone had joined the call, and
he was trying to figure out who it was.
The person had their camera off, and was making
a rather loud sound over the mic.
It sounded like some kind of machine part,
or like a camera zooming in and out.
The username was just: ARIS.
I don’t know anyone at our school named
Aris.
And that was the moment I knew: we were being
eavesdropped by a clown!
I grabbed the nearest weapon I could find…
no, no of course not, it was obviously one of
those pranks you see online where people hack
into a video conference and create havoc.
I had heard the security on this program is
basically non-existent, but this would have
been the first such intrusion that I had experienced.
Despite thinking it was a prank, there was
something about that noise that I found kind
of creepy.
Maybe this class was about to actually be
interesting!
However after a few minutes of nothing happening,
Aris left, and I turned my attention back
to our private Discord chat, where Sinclair
would explain his findings from mapping the
data.
The first major takeaway was not what I expected:
he told us that all the attacks had taken
place in the US, meaning that the clown attacks
happening around the country were probably
from an American organisation.
The second was more the type of observation
I’d expected him to say.
He showed us that all the points on the map
could be connected by major highways and provided
another graphic with this linear connection
to all the affected schools.
Not realizing I was onto something, I told
him it looked like one of those tour maps
you see on a band’s website, or at least
one of those tour maps you USED to see on
band websites before organizers started cancelling
all their tours in fear of being the future
targets of clown lockdowns.
The situation had really turned from paranoia
to hysteria when the clown attacks spread
from just happening in classrooms to the point
they affected football games, stage plays,
and even school band concerts, which eventually
led any tours or concerts where kids would
be in attendance to be shut down.
Sinclair told me he made the same connection
about the map, because of COURSE he did.
He had already pulled data from thousands
of tours that had taken place from 2018, when
the attacks started to get bad, until now.
Apparently these ticket-broker websites also
did not have the most secure information.
So he was basically able to lay these tour
maps on top of our map and see which ones
looked similar.
That narrowed our search down to 97 music
acts, 16 book tours, 7 YouTuber tour… things,
31 comedy shows, 4 traveling magicians…
and three… country-wide... circus tours.
Furthermore, all three circus tours were put on by the same company: an operation by the name of Park
du Soleil.
Apparently that was as much research as Sinclair
had time for, but he wanted to share that
with us.
Our obvious next step would be to look into
this Park du Soleil.
I heard the garage door open.
Must have been my dad getting home.
I figured I’d better look like I’m paying
attention to this class when he gets in here,
so I minimized our Discord chat and brought
back up the Zoom lecture.
“...leading some to question whether the
1975 regulations act was still effective years after...
Excuse me?
Excuse me, who is making that sound?”
It was the zooming sound that we’d heard
earlier -- the one that was coming from the
“Aris” account.
Only, that account was no longer in the call.
I scanned through the class on my screen and
it was indicating that the sound was coming
from Calvin Sinclair’s microphone.
He was looking around, as if he was trying
to determine the source of the noise.
Then I saw him typing, and heard the familiar
[discord sound] notification sound.
I flipped back to our private chat.
He was telling us he could hear that sound
in his house now, which was kind of freaking
him out.
My Dad came into the house from the garage,
so I switched back to my class, and as I did
so I noticed… someone was standing behind
Sinclair… only, it wasn’t a family member,
at least as far as I could tell.
The person was wearing a yellow clown suit!
Before I could say or do anything, I saw the
clown lower its head even with Sinclair’s,
so that it was in the frame and we could all
see the bionic eye and robotic jawline that
amplified the already terrifying appearance
of the red and white face painted nightmare
character!
I once more heard that unsettling sound as
the bionic eye zoomed back out.
Since it was now right next to my friend’s
head, it startled him -- and he jumped away from
it as he realized how close the intruder really
was, but in that same moment, the clown’s
robotic jaw opened and emitted a purple gas
substance into my friend’s face, which he
immediately started choking on as he fell
out of frame.
The entire class was frozen, with shocked
looks on their faces.
It would have been easy for Mr. Hardesty to
chalk this up to an elaborate prank, but given
the climate of recent events, he sat there,
stunned, probably not able to process what
he should say or do.
I could feel my heart pounding in my chest
in the short moments that this all went down,
but what would happen next would cause it
to sink to a place in my chest that I had
never felt it before.
One more time, we all heard the zoom-in sound
of the clown’s bionic eye, as it took control
of Calvin’s computer and furiously typed
away, as if it were someone trying to urgently
write down an idea before the moment passed.
His screen then glitched before going black.
Seeing the look of fear on my teacher’s
face was strangely unsettling.
Maybe it was the idea that he’s supposed
to be an authority figure and he’s supposed
to know what to do when something bad happens
-- and he didn’t.
Or maybe it was the fact that we were no longer
safe anywhere -- even inside of our own homes.
Either way, I can never forget that look he
had.
The rest of the class was cancelled, and Podge
and I desperately tried to contact Sinclair
to see if he was OK.
We mulled over the idea of showing up to get
answers.
The police had obviously been called, so it
seemed like a safe place to be, but I think
we both feared for the worst.
We had just about decided on a plan when I
heard something that made me freeze.
*zoom*
I slowly turned in horror to see that there
was someone standing AT MY WINDOW.
The same clown that had attacked Sinclair
30 minutes ago was now coming after me.
My head spun and my insides did somersaults.
I realized what must have happened.
It was somehow using the computers to find
us in real life.
It started when “Aris” had joined in the
Zoom call.
That’s when it found Sinclair’s location,
then it used his computer to get to the next
in line, which may have been me.
Or maybe there was one before me -- who knows
at this point.
In a panic, I fumbled my way out of my chair,
knocking it over as I did so.
I didn’t turn my back on the cyberclown,
which caused me to go full-horror movie protagonist
and slip and stumble my way away from the
window.
But it was also the reason that I was looking
in that direction when…
*CRACK*
Something lashed out from outside the window
frame and struck the clown around it’s left
eye, the non-bionic one.
The clown let out an inhuman scream and fell
to the ground.
That’s when I saw my Dad, wielding an old
hockey stick from the garage.
He whacked the clown several times on the
ground.
On the third hit, the stick seem to get caught
on something and stuck in place.
He tried to pull it back, and finally pulled it
hard enough for the blade to break away from the
handle.
We would later find the blade totally deformed
in the yard, as if it were a chewed up toothpick.
My Dad came back inside and locked us in the
basement as he called the police.
We didn’t see the cyberclown again.
The police showed up, collected the evidence,
and that was about it, as they were probably
off to make a report of the next clown attack.
I tried to listen in during the short time
they were there.
One of them mentioned something about the
mayor planning to issue a mandatory stay-at-home
order for all kids -- and how that idea wasn’t
going to do much good if the attacks are now
happening in residential neighborhoods…
We never found out what happened to Sinclair.
He’s STILL missing.
Things have only gotten worse.
I talked to Podge again tonight.
He too, was shaken, but we both agreed that
the police weren’t doing enough.
We wanted to continue the investigation that
Sinclair started.
And that began with looking into this circus:
Park du Soleil.
We found out it was started in the mid 2000s
by a guy named Otis Park.
So that’s where our search would have to
begin.
I haven’t seen another clown since that
day.
But sometimes, in the dead of the night,
I still think I hear that sound.
*zooooom*
*click*
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total today comes out to $19.75 but if
you like this video right now I’ll waive
that fee and give you everything you just
listened to absolutely free.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, RING that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.